miss plana how are you i'm fantastic
today are you people are saying that
we're operating on the union schedule
that's right unions suck
if uh
you suck for being late
no we're not late what do you mean union
schedule means that you'd get all of
these different
breaks you ever ever uh had to interact
with a union worker
i'm not going to say where this happened
to me but uh i one time went to a
facility and at the facility hold on at
the facility you know what they said
uh we we need to take a break i said
what we just started they said yeah we
get a 15-minute break i said what they
say yeah we get 15-minute break it's
part of the union
okay and i was there and i was waiting
they took a 15-minute break they
literally just went and sat down and
just looked and they got him i'm telling
you we're going to break
sometimes
we just need a break i'm going strong
with the union of the best business
listen some unions because of the
factory situation okay i get why they
were created i get they were trying to
help you don't get like white collar
unions is what you're trying to say no
they're stupid okay by the way i have a
white collar on
if you're in like
some of these places we'll we'll talk
about it just let's just start talking
we're gonna talk a lot about free
markets today so this is interesting
ready
uh goldman sachs
crushed analyst expectations on strong
bond trading results and its shares rose
three percent what do you talk about
goldman sachs the first topic is bitcoin
what is going on
talk about union
there's a union performance going on
here at the moment
i'm on a union schedule goldman sachs
isn't even listed on about what i want
to talk about do you want to just skip
to banks no we can start with bitcoin
all right what do you want to say about
bitcoin
do you have a topic oh yeah i do have a
topic oh yeah
it went up to 22
or 22 000
or something
bitcoin has topped 22 000 what do you
think about that
i think that's great because it's going
in the correct direction
[Laughter]
you thought bitcoin was headed in the
wrong direction before somebody's asking
if i graduated high school no guys
i graduated middle school
one of my favorite things that polina's
ever told me is that when she came from
bulgaria at what nine years old eight
years old eight at eight years old she
said that in bulgaria uh they were
solving for x in like second grade that
you know like x equals two and uh she
got here and in american math class they
were like one plus one equals two and
and we were solving for x in first and
second grade when i came here i don't
know why but i skipped third grade flex
and then
and then they put me in fourth grade and
in fourth grade in the united states of
america kids were so they're like the
math problems were like three plus seven
and i was like are you guys kidding
right now i was a genius for a solid
like five years and then it all went
downhill well and then americans caught
up see it's a tortoise versus hair you
all may you all had us in the first half
you all had us in the first half but
what about now no it's because i had a
second level bulgarian education and the
americans kind of like what's nine times
nine what's nine times ninety one ooh
that was good that was very good all
right what do you uh with bitcoin what
is it 22 000
uh here's my word of caution i have no
clue did we hit the bottom i don't know
are we going up higher i don't know are
we going down lower i don't know and i
think uh
people get very excited when the price
goes up especially when it's been bad
news bad news bad news bad news bad news
i don't know what's going to happen
i'm
excited when it goes up
i'm not excited when it goes down just
like everyone else i'm human
but it is important to remember
that
in an asset like bitcoin as in the stock
market many other assets where the
dollar
will get depreciated against the asset
the timeless investing principle of
dollar cost averaging into an asset that
you want to hold for a really long
period of time tends to work the best so
you read however you want into that uh
that's my thoughts on it i don't have
very much uh else to say what's up with
the banks so the banks are doing well
that's what i was trying to say
so if a recession were to arrive in the
us there would normally be evidence of
pain at america's biggest lenders but so
far top banks aren't seeing major signs
of weakness people giving me a shout out
they're saying i look extra rested today
you know why i slept eight and a half
hours last night
i went to sleep and when i woke up i was
like where am i
i was so deep in sleep i didn't know
that what awake meant yeah and then you
woke me up for no good reason okay
that's how life works um in terms of the
banks of course banks are gonna do well
why
any time that you have economic
volatility to the upside or downside
banks can figure out a way to make money
and when you look at something like
interest rates going up guess what bonds
tend to be able to deliver some type of
return and banks are huge traders of
bonds that's one key piece a second
piece is that banks have had an absolute
heyday
going out and lending mortgages for
quite a while now one of the key things
that i would argue is that there's also
in a transitionary period where mortgage
rates started to rise
and the psychology of the market hadn't
changed yet there was still plenty of
people who were like man i want that 2.5
that 2.75 maybe even a 2.8
mortgage and it's 3.2 there's not really
that big of a difference and so they
were still borrowing as if there were
super super low rates even into 3.5 up
into 4
and then eventually it got to the point
where psychology changed but there was a
window in time where people were still
borrowing and thought the party was
going on but they were paying more on a
percentage basis and so banks also
benefit from that as well my question is
like
well what are the investment bankers
doing i mean there's no deals that are
getting
closed and done well
and i asked that question investment
bankers just so we're all clear here
they don't need deals to be done to make
money
how much do you think investment bankers
have been paid on the elon musk twitter
saga
why because how much have lawyers been
there they're billing hours in many
cases lawyers specifically right the
lawyers are making a field they're like
dude we hope this never gets solid
however investment banking revenue at jp
morgan fell 61 last quarter and morgan
stanley dipped 55 so that's pretty
significant because also i bet you if
you overlay that with ipos yes if you
overlay that with ipos also m a same
thing so like it is directionally
correct that less deals that get done
obviously investment banking uh gets
less revenue but there is an element of
uh fee generation for all sorts of
services whether it's lawyers
accountants investment bankers whatever
they still can make some money even if
deals don't get done okay all right
what's next flying taxis yeah so virgin
atlantic airways not to be confused with
virgin galactic right that's the thing
so not going to space but on earth right
they are carrying out test flights using
a flying taxi model from uk startup
vertical aerospace as the futuristic
technology moves closer to becoming a
reality you know
vtols
why i actually think this could work
dumb why
uh it's called a helicopter
okay it's not called a helicopter
no literally a vertically taking off uh
thing that can carry people's health
creeps out by helicopters this is why he
doesn't like it yeah i'll follow the
helicopters
not exactly my thing
so but you don't think this is cool
what's cool about it well
they're completely sure if you get the
cost of a helicopter down enough where
anyone and everyone can take it to move
from point a to point b
but here's the problem with a lot of
these ideas is everyone always thinks
like oh this is going to be amazing and
then you're like oh the government
controls the faa and the faa is like we
ain't going to allow this that's what i
was going to say i got enough stuff up
there flying around you and i
in a two-year span in new york city
how many helicopter crashes oh i don't
want to talk about them they scare me
did we either witness or did we hear
there was one
on the uh west side of new york on the
what on the west side of manhattan where
the helicopter was coming in they were
trying to land and uh i believe that
they missed and they teetered and they
fell into the water thank god the pilot
was able to get out and there was only
one injury if i remember correctly
because the guy stopped his toe no he
twisted his ankle there was a guy who
twisted his ankle trying to help
but that was the first one and then the
second one unfortunately the helicopter
pilot died it was raining and he was
coming into one of the high rises and he
hit the high rise and it created like i
think an electrical fire and there was a
third one and it was just a massive i
was on the street when it happened not
right there but like blocks away and i
remember she's like
and then they came out that there was
this huge helicopter uh that crashed in
the building right but wouldn't these be
a little bit more um safe because
they're kind of like small airplanes
they're helicopters i don't know
my my kobe my huge thing in all of this
is always uh
where there is potentially value created
people will go and they will try to
build solutions uh also there was a
third helicopter that i'm remembering
the the intern
was it the intern the business and
center intern was that the one who got
caught
let's not go because i don't remember
the details i'm just gonna say how i
remember it and maybe maybe i get it
wrong maybe i get it right which is
there was a helicopter it had uh taurus
civilians on it i wasn't like some you
know billionaire or whatever and uh it
crashed into i think it was the hudson
and as part of the like prep for the
helicopter uh they basically have a
seatbelt cutter right and the seatbelt
cutter there's like a little quick like
tutorial hey if in the event that we
crash into the river uh take the
seatbelt cutter cut your seatbelt and
swim out from the uh the helicopter
sounds like a pretty uh uh pretty tough
thing to do uh in the military we train
soldiers to do that uh in case they're
in that situation now we have civilians
being estimated and so in that uh
specific incident uh the helicopter went
down in the river uh the pilots uh that
works for the company were able to both
cut their seat belt and they were able
to swim out but unfortunately the
civilians were trapped and did not get
out and so when you look at that stuff
that is in i don't know how many
helicopter flights there are in a single
year in new york city but those are just
three incidents that happened in what
the last
four years five years
yeah i don't know it's scary one time
though in iceland those are helicopters
we went in a helicopter in iceland that
was my birthday gift for him i peed my
pants but
but like they like land you near a
volcano or something and it's like where
the earth split yeah i was more scared
of the hole in the earth than i was in
the helicopter but i didn't like it
everything about iceland i would if this
was the united states there you would
have to sign waivers like you would they
would never let you get that close to
the edge of the earth where like i was
looking over and my stomach was dropped
now i gotta get out of here and so the
the pilot she was like get closer so i
can take a picture of you guys he's like
i'm good right here you did not want to
get close to that nah she was like get
closer i was like you get closer lady
i'm not getting close okay
and the photo i was like just make it
look like i'm standing close
maybe tomorrow's show i'll provide a
photo it's pretty crazy
okay what's going on with the brain
computer interface now that we're over
the flying taxis so okay i cannot
believe this happened speaking of new
york city a man
had a brain computer interface implant
implanted in his head white purple
gatorade are the best and uh so it's
made up the implant is made up of wires
and electrodes into a blood vessel in
the brain and they they put it in the
brain of a patient with als and so the
hope is that he's lost his ability to
like move and speak that he'll be able
to serve surf the web and communicate
via email and text simply by thinking
the device will translate his thoughts
into commands sent to a computer i
freaking love this stuff
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
humanity has changed forever this is
historic development people have long
talked about the singularity where man
and machine will be melded together
that's what we're watching happen right
here this is the first step first u.s
patient to get a computer implanted in
the brain these things are incredibly
small but they could be absolutely
profound in their impact in the world
i
understand that there are plenty of
people who are nervous who are scared
who don't actually understand what is
happening because i saw plenty of
comments today when i tweeted this
saying oh great now they can send ads to
our brain oh great they're gonna rot our
brains with all the nonsense and spam
yes
there are risks but i think the place
where this is going to be heavily
accepted and encouraged and really drive
research is in the medical field
specifically like the gentleman here who
has als and now there is a potential
solution doesn't mean it's guaranteed to
work doesn't mean that we don't have to
study all the long-term impacts doesn't
mean that there could be side effects
all that is on the table but the promise
that we could take a piece of technology
put it into someone's brain and solve a
specific problem that they have like als
is pretty cool yeah and they've already
actually this is not the first person
they've already um implanted the devices
there's a startup called syncron they've
done this into four patients in
australia who have not experienced any
side effects and have been able to carry
out such tasks as sending whatsapp
messages and making online purchases huh
interesting no see that's the dummy why
dumpster
that they're like oh you can make online
purchases like you're idiots i think the
point is that like you can use your
brain to do things that you just
normally do surfing the web i understand
but i also think there's tons of
responsibility for the people who are
doing this and there's uh ethical
situation and one of the big things that
they should uh
pay attention to is the medical
applications not can i hook up jeff
bezos with more revenue because i can
think about buying something the second
thing that uh i worry about i saw
someone comment about uh being hacked um
i'm gonna forget the name what was the
netflix uh like uh tv show a while ago i
think it was on netflix um that was all
about like washington dc and the
political players and there's a
journalist and there's like people
getting killed
what is it uh anyone remember anyone
right with the guy with the man with the
guy what is it guards house of cards
house cards i think it's in house of
cards uh where
there is i think the president or the
vice president can remember uh has a
pacemaker
and the pacemaker
is uh potentially
they're worried about it being hacked or
there's a scene something to do with the
pacemaker and it's the whole idea of
like if it's an internet of thing
thing and it could be hacked then there
could be issues right so immediately
people jump to like all right cool so
i'm gonna put a computer in my brain
what happens if somebody could like hack
my brain
which i don't know the answer to it but
i'm sure i'm sure i think that that is a
concern as well for people either
psychologically
not wanting to adopt this or it is
actually a risk that needs to be
addressed every time something like this
comes up everybody thinks they have like
an original thought oh what if they can
hack the brain or hack the trip i'm sure
the people working on this have already
thought about that so hopefully they
have put into place things well if
anything that's been taught to us over
the last two years it's that most of the
people we thought were thinking about
stuff didn't really think about it
that's fair that's fine remember when
they were like oh there's a pandemic we
need masks and gloves let's call up our
friends overseas to send it to us
we're not talking about the pandemic i'm
just saying like you would have thought
hey maybe if we're gonna prepare for
stuff
right now did you know that uh right now
at the moment uh oil prices they've been
going to the sky
reach for this guy
you know toy story reference uh do you
know toy story have you ever seen toy
story you've never seen toy story i've
seen toys over the stupid cowboy hat
stupid i don't like it woody stupid
you guys i was way more mature than like
my peasant
you know classmates who are watching
freaking
you
classmates i still watch it sophia and i
are going to do a binge we're going
every time we watch adam sandler movie
then we're going to watch a cartoon
movie back and forth back and forth for
the record yesterday i went to work out
and i was like hey anthony can you watch
the baby he said sure i come back there
legend dad move sure
they're watching the all-in podcast
so there is no toy story
and what was she doing she was watching
she was what she was against she was she
was zoned in she was like tell me about
the inflation chamos
okay
david what do you think about joe biden
she was just sitting there she was just
literally just like all right i got the
information that's being transported
into my brain yes um
she's a genius by the way i know sorry i
taught her how to wave this weekend
i said she learned how to wave and he
said she did not learn how to wave she
was taught how to wave i mean yeah that
is what happened okay
i have a checklist of things if you have
any uh comments as to what else we
should add to the list message me uh so
far waving kissing on demand you know
just lots of oh hugs i got the whole
checklist we're just moving through that
real quick uh last thing i'm gonna say
wait no i have one more topic what are
you doing well before we get to the heat
wave is uh on the whole idea of various
movies to watch and different types of
content uh the other thing that i
believe is very important is uh exposure
to many different ideas and so this
weekend i was supposed to be reading i
told planet i'm gonna read and then all
of a sudden i started to watch a
documentary on my phone
and then it was 45 minutes so i just got
i'd do this real quick and polina
started getting mad at me
and so i hit her with i'm learning
do you want do you want to tell the
people about the jay-z thing you watched
oh that that's another actually i
watched two documentaries back-to-back
when i'm supposed to be reading uh jay-z
did a interview with kevin hart which i
didn't know kevin hart had a show
heart-to-heart uh it's on peacock that's
probably no but it's on youtube now it's
uh
is it not i don't want to encourage
people to go watch pirated content but
uh if you happen to search on youtube
kevin hart jay-z you may or may not find
a uh a thing that looks very similar to
the interview in the episode on peacock
uh and so um if you go and you watch it
uh it's fantastic jay-z is uh obviously
one incredibly intelligent two has great
uh kind of rise uh through the years but
he is probably more open i think and
honest uh than i've seen in most other
interviews and so uh it's definitely
worth uh going to check out again it's
on peacock you should watch it on
peacock but if you happen to not have
peacock like me and you search on
youtube uh jay-z kevin hart you may or
may not find something that looks very
similar to the episode okay
go ahead all right um and then and then
we have 30 seconds oh somebody said
train her to burp talk about sophia she
i sometimes i burp on come command and
she laughs and plana hates it no okay we
have 20 seconds left the uk is racing
for the hottest day on record with the
highs of 106 fahrenheit this is not the
hottest day on record no no four then no
i understand but it's just because they
because humans have small brains and we
only started uh actually recording this
in recent history but i'm sure it was
hotter at some point previously
freaking out because in i mean 106
degrees in miami is nothing but we also
have ac as they don't have ac in the uk
a lot of people in europe do not have ac
well they should just do what we're
strong and powerful enough but i was
reading morning brew today and i thought
it was hilarious what they said about
this they were like it's so hot in
europe europeans might actually start
putting ice in their drinks now
well
what i think uh they should do is they
should do exactly what the settlers to
america did when the settlers came to
america there was no uh air conditioning
instead what they did is they simply
built buildings with really high
ceilings that were able to cool
themselves they were much smarter they
were better architects than we are today
oh that was from europe they took that
idea that was the point that was the
point was the europeans already figured
this [ __ ] out that'd be all right drink
some water you'll be good have a great
day guys